parmi les sujets qui buzz aujourd'hui on
revient sur cette photo qui agite les
réseaux sociaux on y voit une feuille
d'allocations de près de 6000 euros
d'aide accordé à une famille un montant
qui a choqué les internautes et provoqué
une vive polémique à l'occasion
généreuse transférée de la poche de ceux
qui travaillent du matin au soir vers
celles de ceux qui sont au foyer et au
chômage cette polémique intervient alors
que Fabien Roussel président du Parti
communiste vient de relancer le débat
sur les allocations je cite la gauche
doit défendre le travail et ne pas être
la gauche des allocations des minima
sociaux alors 6000 euros d'aide accordé
une famille êtes-vous choqué
voilà alors
Gilles Verdez pas choqué pas du tout
c'est la France que j'aime la France qui
aide les gens pauvres c'est une famille
extraordinaire une famille qui n'a pas
de ressources les deux parents sont RSA
c'est des gens méritants et l'arbre la
somme est exceptionnelle mais c'est
parce qu'il y a la location de rentrée
scolaire qui est pas là tous les mois
mais je trouve ça formidable ça c'est la
France que j'aime on est de légende
ouais bravo Béatrice je trouve ça très
choquant pour des gens qui par exemple
travaillent toute la semaine qui gagne
le SMIC et à côté de ça il y a des gens
qui font 10 enfants et on retourne dans
l'histoire de la maison de l'horreur ou
le le fils disait que ses parents
faisaient des enfants pour toucher des
allocations familiales je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose qui va pas il faut que
le travail gagne plus que de ne pas
travailler
Mathieu piston j'ai évidemment une
mauvaise foi je pense que tous ceux qui
ont mis nom là c'est vraiment parce
qu'il y a trois caméras parce que si on
est honnête évidemment il y a des gens
qui ont besoin de location pour le reste
on sait aussi que c'est un sport
national souvent en France de tout faire
pour avoir des locations et même s'il y
a des enfants 6000 euros nets on parle
de net là 6000 euros net ce sont des
gens qui sont qu'on a posé 6000 euros
net j'ai dégagé
des potes qui qui ont fait 10 ans
d'études qui ne gagnent pas ça qui sont
ingénieurs et qui bossent de tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours de
8h du matin jusqu'à 19h et qui ne gagne
pas ça et qui paie beaucoup d'impôts
bien sûr que on est en train bienvenue
en France bienvenue en France
franchement ça devient ça devient
ridicule on parlait avant les élections
de personnes effectivement c'est le gros
problème des gens en ce moment à partir
du 15 du mois et je le vois tous mes
potes je vous le jure je le vois avec
tous mes potes à partir du 15 du mois
qui sont à 0 6
on peut aider les gens sans pour autant
leur servir un plat j'ai cette
hallucinant quand même Delphine tu es
d'accord avec Mathieu oui je pense que
les gens doivent se responsabiliser
parce que que quand on accueille un
enfant ou quand on décide de faire un
enfant il faut que certaines choses
soient réunies effectivement il faut
qu'on soit aimant mais il faut aussi
qu'il y ait enfin qui est pas une
précarité quand même dans la famille que
au moins une des deux personnes puissent
travailler pour pouvoir nourrir l'enfant
et donc à ce moment-là peut-être qu'on
peut en faire un on peut en faire deux
mais en fait on en pas 10 en pensant que
la France va subventionner et aide donc
moi effectivement ça me choque et je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait un
plafond pour vraiment ne pas citer les
gens à continuer proportionnellement à
faire des enfants
je suis exaspéré par ce qui met oui en
fait je trouve c'est vraiment le les
analyses niveau bar des sports c'est à
bas les pauvres ils ont qu'à travailler
ils font des enfants pour les
allocations vous connaissez pas le
parcours de vie de cette famille tout le
monde voit alors oui ça choque les
réseaux parce qu'on voit 6000 euros
c'est pas 6000 euros faut enlever 2000
euros donc c'est une location qui est
versée pour pour la rentrée c'est une
famille où il y a 10 enfants plus de
parents il y a 12 personnes donc pardon
je pense pas
qu'il mène la vie de château et puis
voilà arrêtez de voir la vie à travers
votre prisme à vous il y a des gens qui
sont pas armés de la même manière qui
ont pas les mêmes parcours de vie
peut-être qu'ils ont des parcours de vie
compliqués et heureusement qu'il y a des
aides sociales en France c'est le
dernier le le dernier avant la rue
d'aide donc heureusement qu'on est dans
un pays qui aide les gens qui sont dans
le besoin et qui n'ont pas la même chose
que tout le monde
tu vas pas 6000 euros avec une
allocation de rentrée sinon c'était pour
12 c'est déjà moins fort
on dit effectivement c'est tout à
l'honneur qu'il y ait des aPL c'est tout
à l'honneur qui est des allocations de
rentrée pour les enfants c'est tout à
l'honneur de la France qui est toutes
ses aides on remet absolument pas ça en
cause simplement moi je pense
effectivement que mettre un plafond
mettre un plafond pour dire attention
c'est pas parce qu'au-delà de 4 enfants
vous n'aurez pas plus donc si vous si
vous décidez de faire des enfants c'est
en conscience et faites des enfants en
fonction de ce que vous pouvez leur
offrir comme comme vie y compris
on aide tu as deux un enfant deux
enfants trois enfants cette situation
est compliquée très bien on t'aide mais
de trois ou quatre ou cinq enfants on
arrête tu as tu as atteint ton plafond
maximum d'aide Castaldi moi ce qui me
dérange c'est qu'en fait la manipulation
de cette fille qui a été sortie de son
contexte effectivement il y a forcément
des gens qui exagèrent oui peut-être les
gens qui trichent qui prennent des
allocs externes franchement pointé du
doigt des gens qui ont besoin d'aide je
trouve ça scandaleux et excuse-moi dans
quelle ville on va contrôler l'essence
alors vous avez droit à 5 pas 6 enfants
il y a des gens qui ont un enfant
supplémentaire pour les allocations donc
je te le jure ne dites il y a quelques
cas particuliers peut-être mais c'est
une fois que c'est pas des cas
particuliers au point de ça du doigt on
dit voilà c'est un abusé c'est c'est
juste la situation qui est je pense que
merci
beaucoup il y avait déjà 7 8 ans j'ai
travaillé déjà et ensuite ils sont
tombés dans une situation
avant on le sait pas maintenant ça reste
choquant de 5 millions même si tu
enlèves la rentrée scolaire tu arrives
quand même à
3700 euros je ne vais pas travailler
vraiment 3700 € à deux je ne vais pas
travailler 6000 euros au mois d'août je
ne retournerai jamais travailler même à
10 enfants je ne retournerai jamais
travailler il faut être taré pour aller
travailler tu ne toucheras jamais 6000 €
en allant travailler donc c'est une
réalité peut-être qu'à un moment donné
il faut dire aux gens si vous n'avez
jamais travaillé de votre vie arrêtez à
un moment donné au bout du 6e aux 6e
enfant si vous n'avez jamais bossé en
France c'est pas la peine de faire un
six ou septième enfant on ne vous aidera
plus on va vous aider pour 5-6 enfants
après stop terminé et les gens qui
disent oui mais les riches ils ont droit
de faire autant d'enfants qui veulent
mais les riches font des enfants parce
que les riches ne touchent pas d'aide
donc si un riche il fait 10 enfants il
va les nourrir tout seul moi je pense
aux gens qui toucheront jamais 3700
euros dans leur vie ils ne toucheront
jamais moi je retourne jamais travaillé
3007 je reste chez moi
et c'est pour ça que moi je suis
complètement Fabien Roussel team et
pourtant Fabien Rousset justement
et pas les allocations parce que quand
on sait Cyril par exemple un instituteur
en moyenne c'est 2400 un éboueur c'est
1500 une caissière c'est 1200 une
infirmière c'est 1700 et je parle brut
hein il y a des gens qui disent
forcément c'est un scandale
ou profiter du système ces deux choses
différentes il y en a beaucoup qui
profitent du système ça c'est ce qui
revient sur les réseaux sociaux bien sûr
c'est juste qu'il faut arrêter de mentir
après après je pense sincèrement je vous
dis que Gilles Verdez représente tout ce
qu'il y a loupé non mais c'est vrai tout
ce qui a loupé tout ce qui représente il
représente tous les échecs de de de ces
25 dernières années en France mais c'est
vraiment c'est la une politique
gouvernementale à l'ancienne qui a
depuis des années et des années étaient
voué à l'échec et Gilles Verdez
représente cette vieille France cette
ville voilà
merci
et Gilles Verdez
Gilles pour moi représente la spirale de
l'échec non mais vraiment je vous jure
que c'est vrai
non mais je dis la vérité franchement
je vous dis on veut tous aider les gens
on veut tous mais à un moment donné faut
qu'il y a un retour quelqu'un qui a
bossé 15 ans 20 ans qui a eu un parcours
de vie un accident la femme elle
travaille pas de lui donner 3700 on lui
donnera il a fait un geste il a fait des
efforts pour la France il a travaillé
mais on sait qu'il y a des gens en
France que nous qui n'ont jamais
travaillé en France et tous ces montants
là des chroniqueurs autour de la table
on est tous d'accord pour ça maintenant
moi je ça me dérange pas de donner aux
gens si les gens ont donné quelque chose
des fois tu vois des familles moi je
connais des familles les deux sont en
bonne santé ils sont en pleine bourre
ils peuvent aller bosser n'importe où
ils te disent qu'est-ce que je vais
aller me faire chier aller bosser chez
Leclerc chez Carrefour je prends 2000
balles par mois et Carrefour surtout que
tu oublies que pour gagner 6000 € net
quelqu'un qui travaille quelqu'un qui
travaillerait normalement doit gagner
10000 bruits gagne 10000 € brut en
France qui gagne 0,00
c'est tous les gouvernements alors qui
ont été qui ont pris des mesures qui ont
été des échecs retentissants vraiment et
lui il est encore là-dedans Gilles
Verdez c'est que voilà je vais vous dire
de son sujet Verdez avait des bonnes
idées pour la France ça serait non mais
vous êtes là d'ailleurs bonsoir
alors ce que j'entends c'est scandaleux
c'est-à-dire que là ce que vous êtes en
train de dire c'est [ __ ] de pauvre
[Musique]
tais-toi parce que là ce que tu viens de
dire ça c'est dégueulasse de leur dire
ça c'est dégueulasse que c'est de la
c'est vraiment c'est de la démagogie
c'est nul
non non c'est nul ce que tu dis c'est
nul ce que tu dis parce que tu veux
retourner les gens et tu veux arrête
c'est nul ce que tu dis c'est pas du
tout ce qu'ils ont dit c'est pas du tout
ce qu'ils ont dit tu es elle a vraiment
tu me déçois encore ils ont dit tu
représentes
[Rires]
l'échecs
ça te parle
vraiment vraiment
ils peuvent pas travailler il y a pas de
souci on les aide les gens des gens
Gilles des gens en parfaite santé
parfaite santé ils n'iront pas
travailler bien sûr le système est fait
comme ça un moment donné quand tu
arrives à 16008 ça ne sert plus à rien
d'aller travailler il va falloir que tu
payes ton transport il va falloir que tu
payes ta bouffe ta bouffe le midi il va
falloir que tu donnes
la cantine de tes enfants tu payes taxe
d'habitation il va falloir que tu payes
plein de trucs de l'essence une
assurance pour une voiture le mec il a
raison 3 nous 7 mais je reste chez moi
mais à quelle heure
vous avez ce qui représente
merci Géraldine non mais franchement
Gilles je te le jure tu sais quoi
je m'énerve après toi parce que tu sais
que je t'aime beaucoup mais je pense que
tu es vraiment c'est des gens comme toi
qui font qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la
dans la situation dans laquelle on est
tué tu ne sais pas prendre les décisions
tu tu dis n'importe quoi tu veux faire
plaisir à tout le monde et quand on veut
faire plaisir à tout le monde on fait
plaisir à personne tu n'as pas de règle
tu tu tu voilà tu ne sais pas mettre de
un cadre je te jure que c'est vrai et en
fait tu es tu fais de la vieille
politique qui n'a jamais marché et et et
en fait tu veux que je te dise un mytho
parce que tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mytho parce que
c'est pas décollement de racine que tu
as eu c'est un décollement de cerveau
merci qu'est-ce que tu dis moi j'ai lu
sur les réseaux sociaux il y avait le
témoignage d'une personne qui disait moi
à 50 € près j'ai loupé toutes j'ai loupé
les aides et c'est pas quelqu'un qui
roule sur l'or bien évidemment parce que
c'est à 50 € et lui donc cette personne
là sur les réseaux disait bah j'ai droit
à rien et je me saigne aux quatre veines
et en face je me rends compte que les
personnes elles ont 6 fois plus que moi
bien sûr
s'il te plaît je sais pas fais quelque
chose mais reviens neuf
non mais je te le jure tu et tu
représentes tout ce qu'il y a loupé tu
vois pas que la politique que tu es en
train de faire c'est la politique qui
qui a mené la France dans l'état dans
lequel elle est en ce moment arrête un
peu tuer et un moment ouvre les yeux
arrête arrête tu vois bien que ça marche
pas tu vois bien que ça marche pas je
suis qu'une ça marche ça marche ou pas
ça marche pour cette famille qu'il est
beau
mon Gilou
écoute je te dirai mon quand tu gagnes
6000 €. tu vois tu vois un gars mais moi
ce que je dis à chaque fois quand tu
vois avec des familles j'ai plein de
téléspectateurs qui m'écrivent qui me
disent nous on se réveille tous les
jours à 8h du matin on rentre le soir à
20h et ben à la fin le 15 du mois on
peut pas manger on peut pas donner à
manger à nos enfants alors qu'on se
saigne tous les jours on travaille comme
des fonctions travaillaient pas on se
plaindrai pas mais on travaille comme
des fous tous les jours et on arrive à
au 15 du mois on a on a honte de dire à
nos enfants malheureusement je ne sais
pas quoi te faire à manger je ne sais
pas quoi te donner à manger ça ça
franchement ça c'est une admissible
j'aimerais aider ces gens là moi je
pense qu'il vaut mieux trouver aussi une
aide pour les gens qui ont des salaires
qui travaillent parce que il y a pas de
production qui travaillent et qui ne
s'en sortent pas bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
ah oui moi je pense je pense que ces
gens-là moi ça je trouverai ça génial de
leur faire une rallonge et d'ailleurs
voilà il y a une aide pour ces gens qui
se lèvent tous les matins qui se couche
tard le soir qui travaille 6 jours sur 7
et qui à Noël se disent je peux pas
malheureusement mon fils je peux pas
t'offrir un cadeau et ça c'est
insupportable qui gagne 1200 € par mois
qui travaillent de 8h du matin à 8h qui
est épuisé fatigué que seul son enfant
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle en fait elle
fait rien que le problème c'est la
valorisation du travail les allocations
du mouvement des gilets jaunes des gens
qui travaillent toute la journée
et c'est ça n'a pas été les mecs qui
bossent ils bossent du matin au soir et
comment tu m'as expliqué à ta famille à
tes enfants ils disent on voit papa
partir le matin on le voit rentrer le
soir il travaille toute la journée
comment tu vas leur expliquer le
week-end que tu as pas pour aller faire
un cinéma que tabac pour les amener
faire des loisirs comment tu leur
explique ça ils disent papa mais tu
travailles toute la semaine là il faut
des aides pour ces gens-là ça pour moi
ça c'est une urgence je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
quasiment qui vont falsifier leur vie
pour mériter des amis vous rendez pas
compte il y a beaucoup de gens
toi tu le connais
mais alors
pour avoir fait des enfants c'est
inadmissible alors qu'il y en a qui se
lève tous les jours du matin et qui
travaille du matin aussi
je vais te dire la vérité
il y a c'est des décisions de vie je
suis désolé
enfant parce que j'ai pas fait j'ai pas
les moyens de
pour faire des enfants parce que je
voulais leur offrir un cadre de vie un
bon cadre de vie on te dit pas de
supprimer les enfants en cause les aides
on les remet pas encore là
[Applaudissements]
n'importe quoi
non mais en vrai vous faites des
raccourcis qui sont trop faciles
sous-entendez que cette famille jamais
travaillé de sa vie qu'est-ce que vous
en savez ensuite tout le monde s'excite
pas de cette famille
sur 6000 euros par mois ils sont 12
c'est pas 6000 c'est 3700
ça fait 10 euros par jour par personne
tous les jours
n'importe quoi tu crois qu'il m'a
accepté si on propose au papa par
exemple un
club d'éboueur et à la maman
du tout ils ont 300 € par mois par
personne et moi j'entends vraiment et
Géraldine dire les riches ont le droit
de faire des enfants les pauvres n'ont
pas le droit de faire d'informer